Film Courage: What were some of the biggest
mistakes you made in the beginning of your
screenplay writing and how did you realize
they were mistakes?
Aleem Hossain, filmmaker and AR/VR creator,
assistant professor in media arts and culture
at Occidental College: I think…that’s
a good question.
What are the mistakes?
I made all sorts of mistakes when I was starting
to write
But I don’t necessarily think of them as
mistakes and more I think it’s just the
process of learning and I’m happy that I
was able to at the time just keep writing
and writing.
Things that jump to mind when I think of my
particular mistakes.
I think one I was a little scared of trusting
my own point of view.
I think I was relying too much on the models
of screenwriting looking at books on The Hero’s
Journey and three-act structure and others.
I was just obsessed with those things.
I was trying to find an answer in them.
At the end of the day I do think they have
some use but for me I realized that when I
just let go of that and asked myself just
core emotional and dramatic questions…first
of all actually sometimes it would result
in stuff that actually had that structure
anyway inherent in it and even when it didn’t
it still worked so definitely I think sort
of avoiding the structure.
I think honestly also not outlining and spending
enough time planning.
There is such a temptation to feel like you’re
not getting anything done until you type on
the page.
I feel like anything what I’ve learned in
every time I write a screenplay I think now
I spend longer in the brainstorming and then
outlining phase each time realizing that it’s
so easy to think “I just typed a scene!
That means I made progress!”
But if it’s not the right scene, not the
right entry to that scene, not the right character,
not the right time, that time doesn’t really
get me anywhere.
So I’m really trying to like…and it’s
hard to do that.
It’s hard to stay in the brainstorming phase.
It can feel like “Oh my gosh I’m not making
progress.”
Quite literally we use page count as our metric
of progress.
I wrote five pages today.
And I do think that in some ways it is destructive
to creativity like sitting…there are times
where I have sat for an hour staring out the
window and had no good thoughts until the
final two minutes but that one idea was so
good and shaped the whole film, that hour,
the 58 minutes where I didn’t think anything
was worth that two minutes, those two minutes
might be worth weeks of writing just to have
that right brainstorm.
So for sure I think I rushed too quickly into
writing pages was another mistake I made.
And then lastly, I really do believe (it’s
related to outlining) I don’t think you
should start writing the movie until you know
the end.
I think the end of a movie is so important
because it should inform everything that comes
before it.
I think it in some ways no matter whether
you’re making a super clear movie or some
ambiguous movie, whatever the ending is (in
the classic set up of a joke) if that’s
the punchline, the set up has to be right
for it.
And I think writing any pages before you know
where that’s coming is a mistake even if
your ending is open-ended I think you need
to know you’re leading to that.
And so until I know the end I won’t stop
writing.